[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à damas comme inc man le mouvement le
mouvement
c'est mon métier c'est mes lettres mais
offre et ma vie qui fait d'être banni
shake and amour en bas de cette belle
méditation l'échec me fait l'info est le
mot qui tire sa haute confie ça a dit
des périodes saab
berkshire des situations rallye nous
sommes obligés de nous nous serons
contenant une spécialité
le coach est là bas mcalister à la mi
mai qu'il n'y a pas trop tard tu
n'arrêtes un tabac acheté au late three
les lois et les magazines les bandes
dessinées les graphismes rareté nino les
designers graphiques contre le tabac qui
m'ont connu comme spécialité mais charge
bétheny guitare basse faufiler sg on bat
paris finalement taillage makiese
je m'excuse
[Applaudissements]
badstuber lahm design graphique qui met
à profit tous là elle est une terre la
mouche mais celle ci n'a pas été du tout
mais je doute dix ans un hectare design
graphique ou le tome 3 des kits mal à
l'ied à melwood kennouche pour moan et
ta krabey spécialité a perdu près de
mamouth maritime pas d'intimité
mécanisme était donc terreur pour les
décisions comme la qualité on est des
plantes et enfin talent en toi tu as dit
année blanche qui aiment la dame que je
suis un designer graphique olite une
telle qu'une fille betty malheureusement
du coutal et y détaille truc cool ou
talent en toi j'étais un autodidacte qui
traque les codes du design n'a pas les
enseignants on paye ou mais des clients
allemands
du coup à 6,3 et touristes les cotes
vite diplôme national
l'allemagne elle a tenu bon designer
graphique aptes au vol elle m'a dit liam
aaron parallèle contenait le major
contenait le meuble contenait le menu
comme l'altima en scène à bollezeele
kenya ni les bourses à des jeunes cela
on aime le sénégal me battre a dit à
l'afp juste assez stricte
marcel mouche attaques en tout cas de sa
bassine quel message le sénat d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
les black lips est souvent à opposer nos
salles rock à guitares et métal
je compte me connaît donc matinik type
notebook ou car je devais aller trimer
comme schnarf alina capable de table qui
mène unique tab 10.1 imagine coule la
seine et nerveuse litres h et liam de
réaction les manèges misola kent page
robe à de la lutte et les jeunes et
kinect dance music lille comme à nîmes
contre mais qui habite mixte baxe nax de
sourires amusés à nanterre collective
électeurs à travers un art que je
respecte beaucoup qui me pose telle
qu'on relise designer graphique vous
faire de l'italie un design graphique
école compte un talent tout ce qui est
typographie tout ce qui est calligraphie
oui découle magie cheikh gibralta
holy-dis rire qui habite mulhouse là
quelqu'un blakeley muszyna olic table où
les bandes dessinées ou les magazines
par l'homme qui fait la malle peinture
qui fait qu'ils manqueront loana fillon
strictes de bâle et août
talend qui fait le style les matières al
qods on m'a dit 'je suis intal barabé
des chronos livre êtes un artiste
ban a dit mikel malien pour la musique
manouche et arty un jour je serai un
artiste elle m'avait mais cette victoire
ok mon fils comme à lemaitre électorale
mais j'ai kiffé nabeul alger mais le tas
à l'oeil nu qui fait cela bras semaines
les fausses couches
est ce à travers la la lipstick tchoumba
talent ni je fais la liaison entre
calligraphie et graffitis calligraphie
agen habitat dernièrement au graffiti
hadj dit belles choses la base un
travail et un mouvement chez amath raft
mouvement au joug de mon combat avec un
cri trophy mouvement ils s'appellent eux
kelly graffiti lanta qui me protège
comme d'hab on menait jeunes arbres à
l'heure de bouteilles lancées aux
abdominaux commode you can à travers
l'activité it up des oeuvres dynamo mais
l'échec n'était pas hostile méditation
maj le gers les titres à la mer en face
je fais la méditation mais méditation
quant à travers l pinceau kinshasa au
noir peinture qu il s tablit n'est tabou
où l'abbé denis nightmare tout au long
de cette même terre elle y avoir des
dernières monfis dubaï face à 2,40 m de
largeur sur 25 mètres qui coule belkin
radhika femmes ied au cola et la jeune
scène à chaque niveau
nous sommes des dames le relais a dit me
wade indique richard beitia le menu ou
bishi bishi partage hymne à la paix à
travers des oeuvres albertain faire mal
fait que la fille de kate blanche loin
donc voilà je fais la méditation à
travers le calligraphe ici ce que je
fais c'est pas de la calligraphie arabe
en fait ce que je fais c'est un mariage
entre lettres latines
elle a goûté qu'on trouve dans la
calligraphie arabe est d'au moins six
mois avant
au mas les textes et les morts a dit le
texte next ferrand
colom il reflète la situation les
knights libanais saad j'improvise
s'arrête là me charles ghislain juste à
ouvrir contacter madame awa la guerre
qui élit la prostate
dès qu'une seule face à kaboul ap
savannah bay à roulettes les méditations
un one man show de pinceau je me
déconnecte carrément des miens et des
annexes complice camarades in touch
ryan croquis qui reflète le mot
générosité générosité bochenko il serait
l'arc mais la lettre se sont pas des
lettres arts ce sont des mots en anglais
mais avec un esprit orientable allège
allègera terreur mais ne disent qu'une
femme a bridge between two quelque chose
weiss endroit est là aiment le croquis
edf dit d'être bénéfique à la miba a dit
basso ni lénine à bruxelles c'est nadia
alami facebook fishlabs bouteille à
travers ce que je fais aujourd'hui il
est complet avec molette sculpture et la
sculpture bêtises comme vernissage
interview l'exploit ou expositions
personnelles et fait tourner les moteurs
du feu de dieu merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]